so jumping right on in I want to start
by saying and I'm sure you're hearing
this from everyone this movie is [ __ ]
awesome it's incredible I have nothing
but positive things to say and I'm out
that's okay also we need there's no
cursing here I don't know if they told
you that well I mean you're the thing
they like it played it in Toronto and it
won the Audience Award which tells you
how incredible the movie is because the
competition this year wasn't was amazing
um I have to ask the three of you what
was it like reading the script for the
first time because this is what taiga
does with this script is just
unbelievable well that's the word
unbelievable it's its script blew my
mind yes like really unique and
incredible yeah I wasn't really paid to
the movie I just kind of given the
script I said read this and and yeah
immediately was just blown away by and
just lapped it up and gotten photo tiger
and was just so happy that he wants me
to be a part of it I just was excited by
the fact that someone's still willing to
make a movie that is try to be funny and
emotional and have something profound to
say and have an imaginary Hitler in it
mmm
you know you just don't see that very
often anymore well the other thing that
I commend him and Fox Searchlight for is
that we live in this day and age where
everything is so politically correct and
everyone is afraid to go near the third
rail in terms of talking about things
right and this script does that it does
it brilliantly but I mean I would I
would imagine this is a very unusual
piece of material what is ironic though
isn't it because mocking and satirizing
Hitler is something that's been
happening since the forties when Hitler
was stood in powering most famously the
Great Dictator Charlie Chaplin but but
many other films through the 60s with
Mel Brooks certainly growing up in the
UK there were jokes on talk shows about
Hitler and making people dressed up as
Hitler making fun of him should any
right to be or not to be oh yeah so it's
this long tradition and yet suddenly you
you raise the subject now on people like
oh you can't joke about this and so I
don't know where that switch happened
where suddenly we got uncomfortable it
the idea of mocking and satirizing a
dictator I mean isn't that exactly what
you should do or hundred percent yeah
and as you said
in Toronto you know it's a great way to
somebody with a big ego it's a great way
to get at them to humiliate them through
humor mm-hm yeah you know different is
going on right now
on SNL hmm absolutely uh one of the
other things that I think is that it's
more important than ever to remind
people of what happened in World War two
and tell new stories to get a new
generation to acknowledge and understand
what really happened can you sort of
talk about that aspect too well I think
learning about it in school we can only
kind of sort of learn about something so
much with so much shame attached to it
and obviously that you know that
whatever happened was um was horrific
but in terms of teaching those sort of
ideals on lofty ideals in terms of
Nazism but in terms of teaching kids
about how important that is and how
relevant it is today I think you can
find good tools of doing that a positive
way rather than just kind of hammering
it into these kids that you need to
remember this because it was it was
awful you know I think this kind of
teaches that message and in a way more
loving way in a positive way I think
it's a great shame that we're still in
an age where we have to mock and
undermined far-right fascistic ideas
you'd think that we'd put that to bed
but it turns out we haven't and the idea
that you I still have to remind people
of the sort of inanity and the absurdity
of those beliefs and the way that they
just as soon as you plotted them they
fall apart in your hands they have no
weight they no substance and the idea
we've still got to be telling people
this it is a great is a great tragedy a
hundred percent agree I never thought in
the year 2019 we would have to rebait
this right you know what I mean you
thought it was we thought it was done in
dust yeah yeah yeah I second that one
hundred percent um so are you your anti
Nancy's I'm anti nods yes cuz I'm a pro
I do nothing yeah I'm very Pro
anti-fascist there are so many moments
in this movie that made me laugh and
make me think and I mean he make you cry
talk a little bit about making what was
it like on set making this and with what
kind of an environment does tyka sort of
per set up when you're there it was a
lot of fun I thought I mean you know we
working hard seriously you know but it
was also a very fun environment very
free I thought yeah yeah yeah I was
games great Teicher definitely kind of
allowed a looseness to what was going on
which I thought was a great for me I
defined not really been allowed to do
any kind of comedic time or anything
that required it for quite a while so to
be able to come in and do that and just
feel part of a family you know he kind
of he kind of takes people with with him
from movies he's went on for years and
and has takes people with him which is
great we had the moment with the dancing
that was really fun and we just doesn't
like first day on set it was it was
amazing and then you you went you had
all these amazing yet ad-libs well might
might is always entertaining to me to
try and make another actor laugh and you
know Sam I've enormous respect for not I
don't you have we we didn't have scenes
together a flee but we didn't get to
interact in that same way but um but
just try and make him laugh was was the
greatest pleasure to me to try and get
him to ruin a take having just recently
won his Academy Award just seems
particularly entertaining to leave that
was my ambition how do I make some work
Rockwell ruin this take and see like an
unprofessional how many I mean I was
like at first I was like why is he
getting there why is the tiger letting
him ad libbing oh yeah he's a he's a
writer that's why you idiot
he's a really good writer and a really
great actor and and of course his
ad-libs were not just they're not just
you know garnish they're like it's filet
it's it's really it's in tank it was
letting him you know do it do it you
know well I am curious about that
because you are such a great writer what
is it like how much are you the night
before looking at the script and
thinking about like what can I pet her
in and how much are you actually finding
in a moment where you're hearing Sam say
something and you're just flipping it
well it's a little bit of both I mean I
I never would be so presumptuous as to
sort of rewrite a script but if
something occurs to me then I'll always
make a note of it and sometimes like
sometimes I like to try out on the set
if I have to over before just because if
you get a reaction in the moment it kind
of tells you that it's working you know
or that if it makes someone laugh in the
moment then you think oh or maybe we're
onto something but the great thing we
take is that if you have a nugget of an
idea he'll then sort of amplify it and
expand on it because I had made some
joke some kind of ad-lib about you know
the famous the hitter only had one ball
and I made some joke about it you know I
mean they really should know some
outtakes yeah that day was like really
extraordinary it was really something we
had remember that thing we were shouting
at the kids and while they're doing that
the doing the collision yeah yeah yeah
it was crazy
yeah coming into these sort of huge
warehouses full of these crazy uniforms
and then yeah just these kids running
around in them in these you know what
were the version of Boy Scouts in in
those days you know they didn't really
have a choice so it was it was pretty
dystopian at times without a shadow of a
doubt one of the things I found
fascinating was that you guys film part
of this in Prague in the same studio
where they made Nazi propaganda yes so I
found that amazing that you guys were
able to film there did you know you were
filming in the same soundstages or in
the same area well yes and even more
kiddingly we would we were in ten
squares which were addressed in the
start of the 1940s with swastika
insignia where in fact the doctors had
been back in the day so there's
something quite eerie about sort of
seeing that brought back to life in a
place where actually it happened one
driver told me that the uniforms we were
wearing were actual Nazi uniforms from
the period but why one drivers would
know that information I don't know why
he's got the inside track on the hair
yeah I clean since my last question for
you guys or one of the last two well
I've been asking everyone this recently
TV has never been better right now
there's incredible stuff is there
anything you would like to guest star on
oh my gosh
star geez that's a rough that's a rough
black mirrors pretty amazing but mirror
yeah yeah I'd like both feedback fleabag
yeah I am I I'd like to be in succession
I think that would be fun
oh yeah yeah I could see you on though
you and Matthew McFadden go yeah I think
two of these three things are possible
you picked one that is now
oh yes only two series yes yeah yeah
yeah I will go for succession come on
Jonathan glance sir sought me out on
that note I have to go but I mean it
sincerely you guys did incredible work
movie is one of the best of the year
because the night you think